l'orphelinat pour enfin noir de la
nouvelle écosse un endroit qui hante
encore un ancien résident l'enfant a été
retrouvé abandonné dans la rue au début
des années 50 alors qu'il était bébé
il a d'abord été placée dans un
orphelinat pour blanc lorsqu'ils ont
appris que la mer était noir elles nous
ont envoyés ici dit il
pendant huit ans jerry morrison a vécu
l'horreur il a été victime de violences
et de maltraitances et à cause de sa
couleur pâle
il ajoute que les civils c'était encore
pire l'orphelinat était une prison pour
lui il s'imaginait fuir mais n'avaient
nulle part où aller
l'enfer que vivait ses enfants étaient
connus de la communauté
mais personne n'agit jamais au lit
buriné la communauté noire de la
nouvelle écosse est l'une des plus
anciennes au canada et longtemps la
ségrégation était la norme dans la
société
l'orphelinat a été créée dans les années
20 parce que les orphelins noirs
n'avaient nulle part où aller
l'établissement est donc ni du racisme
la population noire de la province et
plus pauvres moins éduqués et compte
plus de chômeurs que la moyenne
le sol nous n'avons pas répondu aux
besoins des enfants afro néo écossais
avait admis le premier ministre en 2014
après des années de bataille juridique
en recours collectif
plus de 300 survivants ont obtenu des
excuses officielles de la province
depuis c'est le long chemin vers la
guérison
un combat mené entre autres par tony
smit un autre survivant de l'orphelinat
une enquête réparatrice est en cours
pour comprendre pourquoi cette
maltraitance a pu continuer pendant des
décennies mais surtout pour donner une
voix à la communauté noire de la
nouvelle écosse
enfin j'ai ouï regardé par la fenêtre et
devait se convaincre qu'il y avait un
monde meilleur
légende lanka et espère aujourd'hui que
leur calvaire aura servi à améliorer le
sort des noirs de la nouvelle écosse et
sinaï la bendali radio canada à halifax